- Bine ai revenit la Înțelegerea Informației și Computației Cuantice.
Numele meu este John Watrous și sunt Directorul Tehnic pentru
Educație la IBM Quantum.
Aceasta este a șaptea lecție din serie și în această lecție vom discuta problema estimării de fază și cum o putem rezolva
cu un calculator cuantic.
Vom aplica apoi estimarea de fază la problema factorizării numerelor întregi, pe care am discutat-o în lecția anterioară.
Ceea ce vom obține este algoritmul lui Shor, care permite factorizarea numerelor întregi
la cost polinomial sau în timp polinomial, dacă preferăm
să gândim în termeni de timp necesar, mai degrabă decât numărul de
operații elementare de care avem nevoie.
Acesta este bijuteriul de coroană al
algoritmilor cuantici în anumite privințe, și deși factorizarea numerelor întregi mari
poate fi de utilitate limitată pentru majoritatea oamenilor, rămâne una dintre cele mai
convingătoare dovezi pe care le avem pentru ipoteza că calculatoarele cuantice vor
oferi avantaje remarcabile
față de calculatoarele clasice. Iată o privire de ansamblu asupra lecției.
Vom începe cu o definiție a problemei estimării de fază în sine, apoi vom discuta o metodă de rezolvare a acestei probleme
cu un calculator cuantic.
Vom proceda pas cu pas, începând cu ceea ce poți
considera un fel de încălzire.
În problema estimării de fază, scopul este de a aproxima
un anumit număr real, iar în această parte de încălzire
vom vedea cum putem obține
o aproximare de foarte mică precizie
a acestui număr.
Aceasta nu va fi
suficient de bună pentru factorizare când aplicăm soluția noastră la
problema estimării de fază pentru factorizarea numerelor întregi,
de fapt vom avea nevoie de o aproximare cu precizie destul de mare, dar este totuși util să începem cu acest fel de încălzire
doar pentru a înțelege
cum funcționează tot mecanismul.
Vom discuta apoi problema obținerii mai multă precizie, ceea ce va conduce foarte
natural la o operație cunoscută sub numele de transformata Fourier cuantică.
Vom vedea exact ce este această operație și cum poate fi implementată
cu un circuit cuantic.
Și odată ce o avem, vom putea să o aplicăm
la estimarea de fază pentru a obține o procedură generală de rezolvare a problemei
cu precizie foarte mare.
Apoi, în ultima parte a lecției, vom vedea cum o soluție la
problema estimării de fază ne permite să factorizăm numere întregi eficient.
Și mai precis, ceea ce vom obține este algoritmul lui Shor pentru
factorizarea numerelor întregi, sau cel puțin ceva echivalent cu algoritmul lui Shor.
Modul în care funcționează este că ne oferim practic
o treaptă intermediară, care este o altă problemă numită problema găsirii ordinului.
Și în special vom vedea cum putem rezolva problema găsirii ordinului folosind procedura de estimare de fază și apoi vom vedea cum
putem factoriza numere întregi
rezolvând problema găsirii ordinului. Vom începe cu un caz special al unei teoreme numite Teorema Spectrală,
și mai precis ne vom concentra pe ceea ce ne spune teorema
despre matricele unitare.
Teorema spectrală este
o teoremă foarte importantă din algebra liniară și
analiza funcțională.
Ne spune ceva interesant despre modul în care anumite aplicații liniare pot fi exprimate într-o anumită formă, adesea numită
descompunere spectrală,
care este utilă din multe motive.
Și cum am spus, ne vom concentra pe ceea ce ne spune această teoremă
despre matricele unitare.
Teorema spectrală este
mai generală decât aceasta. Nu funcționează pentru toate matricele, dar funcționează pentru o clasă de matrice
numite matrice normale, care includ toate matricele unitare, dar și unele matrice
care nu sunt unitare.
Dar doar pentru a simplifica lucrurile, ne vom restrânge atenția
la matricele unitare deocamdată, deoarece asta este tot ce avem nevoie pentru
scopurile acestei lecții.
Iată o formulare a teoremei spectrale doar pentru matricele unitare.
Presupunem că U este o
matrice unitară de dimensiune N ori N.
Ce spune teorema
este că trebuie să existe o bază ortonormată de
vectori, psi unu până la psi N,
împreună cu N numere complexe
Lambda unu până la Lambda N, toate situate pe cercul unitar complex, astfel încât U să poată fi exprimat
cum avem în această ecuație.
Aceasta se numește o descompunere spectrală
a lui U, cum am menționat deja, și poate fi foarte convenabil să știi că U poate fi scris în acest mod.
Poate fi uneori convenabil să ai acești vectori și aceste numere când lucrezi cu
o anumită matrice unitară U, și poate fi, de asemenea, foarte
util pur și simplu să știi
că o astfel de expresie este întotdeauna posibilă, ca modalitate de a demonstra anumite lucruri despre matricele unitare, de exemplu.
În această formulare a teoremei, fiecare dintre aceste numere,
Lambda unu până la lambda N, este scris într-un mod particular
ca E la puterea doi pi I ori theta, unde fiecare dintre thetele
theta unu până la theta N este un număr real, și
vom reveni la acest mod
de scriere a fiecăruia dintre aceste
numere puțin mai târziu.
Un lucru important de observat
despre acești vectori și numere este că fiecare vector psi
K trebuie să fie un vector propriu al matricei U cu
valoarea proprie corespunzătoare lambda K.
Ceea ce înseamnă că dacă
înmulțim psi K cu U, ceea ce obținem este lambda K ori psi K.
Deci ceea ce face U fiecăruia dintre acești vectori este pur și simplu să îl înmulțească cu numărul corespunzător lambda K.
În general, pentru un vector arbitrar, acesta nu va fi modul în care funcționează U, dar vectorii proprii sunt speciali.
Și ceea ce ne spune teorema este că există de fapt
o bază ortonormată a acestor vectori proprii.
Această ecuație de mai jos, apropo, decurge din expresia pe care o avem pentru U din teoremă, împreună cu faptul că
vectorii sunt ortonormați.
WEBVTT
Dacă înmulțești
expresia lui U cu orice psi K și folosești ortonormalitatea vectorilor, vei obține o sumă în care
toți termenii sunt zero
cu excepția unuia, iar singurul termen cu care
rămânem arată astfel.
Acum putem defini
problema estimării de fază.
Problema este puțin
neobișnuită, cum vom vedea.
Ni se dau două lucruri. În primul rând, ni se dă descrierea unui circuit cuantic unitar,
care acționează pe N qubiți
pentru o alegere oarecare a lui N, iar când spunem că acesta
este un circuit unitar,
vrem să spunem doar că toate
gate-urile sunt unitare, deci nu există măsurători
în acest circuit.
În al doilea rând, ni se dă o stare psi cu N qubiți, și aceasta este partea neobișnuită.
De fapt avem o intrare de tip
stare cuantică pentru această problemă, și este o singură copie a acestei stări.
Pentru toate celelalte probleme computaționale despre care am vorbit în această serie, intrarea a fost clasică, fie sub forma unui șir
de biți, fie ca o cutie neagră.
Și asta nu este surprinzător, deoarece problemele computaționale
pe care le întâlnim în viața noastră de zi cu zi tind să fie clasice,
deoarece acelea sunt
problemele de care ne pasă cel mai mult.
Modul în care poți
gândi despre această problemă este că este ceva care apare sau este probabil să apară ca o sub-problemă.
Și procedura de estimare de fază cu care vom ajunge în cele din urmă este ceva ce
folosim în general ca subrutină
în interiorul unei computații mai mari, probabil una pentru o problemă clasică
de care ne pasă.
Acum, aceasta va fi o problemă cu promisiune, iar starea psi nu este
doar o stare cuantică oarecare.
Ni se promite că psi este un vector propriu al oricărei operații unitare U pe care o descrie circuit-ul dat.
Și scopul este de a găsi sau
aproxima valoarea proprie care corespunde vectorului propriu psi.
Să formulăm problema
puțin mai precis.
Intrarea constă dintr-un
circuit cuantic unitar pe N qubiți, care poate fi codificat ca un șir de biți
folosind orice metodă preferăm pentru codificarea descrierilor de circuite cuantice, împreună cu o stare psi de N qubiți.
Putem numi circuit-ul cum vrem, dar ceea ce contează cu adevărat în termeni ai formulării acestei probleme este operația unitară în sine
care se efectuează când circuit-ul rulează, iar acea operație unitară
este descrisă de matricea U.
Dar nu ni se dă U ca matrice, ni se dă doar descrierea unui circuit cuantic care implementează U.
Promisiunea, cum am spus deja, este că psi este un vector propriu al lui U.
Deci dacă rulăm circuit-ul nostru pe psi, am obține psi ieșind înmulțit cu orice ar fi valoarea proprie,
ceea ce ar fi o fază globală
în acea situație.
Și în fine, ieșirea problemei este o aproximare a valorii proprii corespunzătoare lui psi, și mai precis căutăm
o aproximare a numărului real theta, între zero și unu, inclusiv
zero, dar nu inclusiv unu
care satisface ecuația
pe care o avem pe ecran.
Pentru a explica această modalitate de
parametrizare a valorii proprii corespunzătoare lui psi, și, de asemenea, pentru a clarifica ce înțelegem prin aproximare,
să desenăm o imagine a
cercului unitar complex.
Putem plasa numerele unu, I,
minus unu și minus I în pozițiile lor obișnuite și putem considera
un punct arbitrar pe
cerc parametrizat de theta, cum avem în formularea problemei.
Acesta este punctul pe care îl
obținem dacă pornim de la unu și rotim cu un unghi de
două ori pi ori theta, deci unghiul nu este
theta, ci doi pi theta,
iar un alt mod de a gândi despre asta este că dacă pornim de la unu și parcurgem o distanță de doi pi theta pe cerc în sine,
vom ajunge la punctul nostru, E la
doi ori pi ori theta.
Fiecare punct din cercul unitar complex poate fi reprezentat în acest mod
pentru o alegere unică a lui theta.
Și asta deoarece parcurgem
tot cercul pe măsură ce theta merge de la zero la unu, iar dacă am merge tot drumul
până la theta egal unu,
am fi înapoi unde am
pornit la theta egal zero, de aceea includem zero, dar nu includem unu.
Doar pentru a ne asigura că fiecare
punct de pe cercul unitar complex corespunde unei valori unice a lui theta în intervalul pe care îl considerăm.
Există diverse moduri
în care am putea imagina aproximarea unei valori particulare a lui theta, dar modul în care o vom face este să aproximăm theta cu o fracție,
unde numitorul
este doi la puterea M pentru o alegere oarecare a unui număr întreg pozitiv M, iar numărătorul este un număr întreg y
între zero și doi la M minus unu.
Poți gândi aceasta ca o aproximare de m biți a lui theta dacă dorești, și am putea scrie acest
număr în notație binară
unde avem un punct binar urmat de reprezentarea binară
a lui Y.
Spun punct binar apropo,
mai degrabă decât punct zecimal, deoarece zecimal înseamnă baza 10 și vorbesc despre baza doi
aici, dar este aceeași idee.
Dar în orice caz, putem
gândi la fel de bine despre asta ca o fracție cum
apare pe ecran.
Și pentru a fi clar, când ne gândim la
aproximări în acest context, trebuie înțeles că valorile lui theta
WEBVTT
aproape de zero și valorile lui theta aproape de unu sunt de fapt apropiate între ele.
Deci, de exemplu, dacă theta este egal cu 0.99 și aproximăm această valoare
a lui theta prin valoarea zero,
atunci aceasta este o aproximare destul de bună în sensul că se încadrează
în una din o sută din valoarea reală, când
înconjurăm cercul
și revenim la zero când ajungem la unu.
Termenul modulo unu este folosit uneori pentru a descrie situația în care practic
echivalăm theta egal unu cu theta egal zero.
Ideea este că ne pasă cu adevărat de locația punctului
E la doi pi I theta pe cercul unitar,
și gândirea despre această
modalitate de aproximare a lui theta are sens când avem acel scop în minte.
Formularea problemei în sine,
cum apare pe ecran, nu este specifică în privința cât de bună trebuie să fie aproximarea lui theta,
dar acesta este ceva pe care putem regla în funcție de nevoile noastre.
În unele situații am putea fi mulțumiți cu o aproximare de mică precizie
a lui theta, iar în alte situații am putea cere
o aproximare de foarte mare precizie, iar formularea problemei în sine
poate fi rafinată în consecință.
În continuare vom vedea cum putem rezolva
problema estimării de fază cu un calculator cuantic și
vom începe cu o încălzire.
Aceasta nu va fi soluția noastră finală
la problemă.
Ceea ce vom face este să folosim fenomenul de phase kickback pentru a încerca să aflăm ceva
despre valoarea proprie corespunzătoare unui vector propriu dat.
Reamintim că în
problema estimării de fază ni se dă descrierea
unui circuit cuantic unitar pentru o operație U oarecare,
și ceea ce facem mai întâi este să
folosim această descriere de circuit pentru a crea un nou circuit care implementează o operație U controlată, cum
este ilustrat pe ecran.
Aceasta este destul de simplu de făcut. Ceea ce putem face este să adăugăm un qubit de control, care este ilustrat
în vârf în această diagramă
și să folosim acest nou qubit de control
ca un control pentru fiecare gate din
circuit-ul nostru.
Deci toate gate-urile sunt aplicate dacă acest qubit de control este setat la unu, și niciunul nu este aplicat dacă qubit-ul de control este setat la zero,
Asta înseamnă că vom
avea nevoie de o versiune controlată a fiecărui gate care
apare în circuit-ul U, dar nu trebuie să ne gândim
la aceste noi gate-uri controlate
ca gate-uri individuale dacă nu dorim. Ar putea fi implementate
ca circuite mici făcute din gate-uri din orice set de gate-uri
am ales să folosim. Și odată ce avem o
versiune controlată a lui U, putem considera rularea acestui circuit,
unde mai întâi punem qubit-ul de control în o superpozitie de zero și unu, aplicăm gate-ul U controlat vectorului propriu dat care ni se dă,
și apoi aplicăm un gate Hadamard
la control și măsurăm.
Vom vedea de ce are sens să facem asta pe măsură ce parcurgem analiza, dar chiar înainte de a ajunge la detalii, putem observa imediat o similitudine
cu algoritmul lui Deutsch, de exemplu, unde aplicăm
câteva gate-uri Hadamard și măsurăm ca modalitate
de a sonda efectiv
ce face o anumită operație dată.
Este un unitar controlat
mai degrabă decât un gate de interogare, dar există idei foarte similare în joc.
Deci să vedem ce face circuit-ul.
Starea inițială este vectorul propriu psi, în produs tensorial cu starea zero
pentru qubit-ul de control,
aplicând primul gate Hadamard transformă starea
qubit-ului de sus la o stare plus și putem extinde întreaga
stare cum este arătat chiar aici.
Aplicăm apoi operația U controlată, iar ceea ce face este să aplice U la psi când qubit-ul de control este setat la unu,
dar nu când este setat la zero. Deci obținem starea pi doi
care este scrisă pe ecran.
Putem simplifica starea
folosind faptul că psi este un vector propriu al lui U cu valoarea proprie e la doi pi I theta.
Deci obținem că acea valoare proprie înmulțește al doilea
termen, dar nu și primul.
Și putem simplifica folosind bilinearitatea
produsului tensorial.
Deci ceea ce avem aici este fenomenul phase kickback, dar de data aceasta se întâmplă pentru un vector propriu arbitrar psi al unei operații unitare arbitrare U,
spre deosebire de o operație not aplicată unei
stări minus mai specific.
Aceasta este deci starea după aplicarea operației U controlate.
Apropo, merită
să luăm un moment pentru a observa că starea celor N qubiți de jos este în continuare vectorul propriu psi.
Ceea ce este minunat deoarece
ne oferă oportunitatea de a-l folosi din nou dacă alegem.
Apoi al doilea gate Hadamard este efectuat și iată starea pe care o obținem.
Nu am arătat toate
detaliile derivării aici, dar dacă aplici
gate-ul Hadamard și simplifici, asta ar trebui să obții.
Aceasta este deci starea chiar
înainte de măsurare.
Deci ne putem concentra pe această stare pentru a vedea ce putem afla
despre theta prin măsurare.
Și dacă măsurăm qubit-ul de sus
sau qubit-ul cel mai din dreapta, acestea sunt probabilitățile pe care le obținem pentru cele două rezultate.
Și am folosit câteva
formule de bază care leagă sinusurile și cosinusurile
de exponențiale complexe pentru a exprima aceste probabilități
în termeni de sinusuri și cosinusuri.
Mai precis, probabilitatea de a obține zero este cosinusul la pătrat al lui pi ori theta, iar probabilitatea de a obține unu
WEBVTT
este sinusul la pătrat al aceluiași unghi. Și asta are sens
deoarece sinusul la pătrat plus cosinusul la pătrat al
oricărui unghi este egal cu unu.
Deci probabilitățile noastre
se sumează la unu cum ne așteptăm.
Și iată o reprezentare grafică a acestor probabilități în funcție de theta.
Pentru a fi clar, aceasta este o reprezentare grafică a
probabilităților în sine, spre deosebire de o reprezentare a unei singure distribuții de probabilitate, de exemplu.
De exemplu, dacă theta
este egal cu o jumătate, atunci probabilitatea că
obținem rezultatul unu, desenat cu violet, este egal cu unu
în timp ce probabilitatea
de a obține rezultatul zero, desenat cu albastru, este zero.
Pe de altă parte, dacă theta este egal cu
un sfert sau trei sferturi, atunci avem că fiecare dintre cele două rezultate este la fel de probabil.
Și desigur, pentru toate alegerile lui theta, suma probabilităților este egală cu unu, cum am observat deja.
Deci nu aflăm exact ce
este theta din această procedură, dar ne oferă totuși ceva
informații despre theta.
Și dacă ne imaginăm o situație în care ni se promite
că theta este egal cu zero sau theta este egal cu o jumătate, această procedură ne va spune
exact care dintre cele
două posibilități este.
Deci acesta este un mod simplu în care putem folosi fenomenul phase kickback pentru a afla ceva despre valoarea proprie.
Deci cum putem afla mai multe
despre valoarea proprie?
Ei bine, aceasta este o situație în care putem lăsa
ignoranța să ne ghideze.
Deoarece nu există prea
multe lucruri pe care le putem face.
Nu știm aproape nimic
despre vectorul propriu psi, și nici nu știm
prea mult despre operația U.
Avem un circuit pentru U, dar pentru tot ce știm ar putea fi
un dezastru groaznic și confuz pe care nu vom putea
să-l înțelegem examinându-l.
Dar o opțiune naturală este să rulăm circuit-ul de mai multe ori.
În particular, am putea încerca să facem exact același lucru pe care tocmai l-am făcut, cu excepția că în loc de aplicarea unei singure operații U controlate,
aplicăm acea operație de două ori. Sau am putea să o aplicăm de oricâte ori, dar să începem cu de două ori
doar pentru a vedea ce se întâmplă.
Ei bine, ce se întâmplă este de fapt destul de
simplu. Prin aplicarea operației U controlate de două ori, efectiv
ridicăm la pătrat valoarea proprie
deoarece va fi introdusă în
faza qubit-ului de sus de două ori, nu doar o dată.
Și deci când ne gândim la
probabilitățile de rezultat în funcție de theta, practic
dublăm frecvența.
Pentru fiecare alegere posibilă a lui theta, probabilitățile de rezultat
sunt aceleași cu ce ar fi dacă am dubla theta și apoi
am lua partea fracționară
pentru a obține un număr între zero și unu.
De exemplu, dacă theta
este egal cu o jumătate, atunci valoarea proprie este minus unu.
Deci aplicând U de două ori practic ridicăm la pătrat valoarea proprie și rezultatul este același cu cel pentru theta egal zero.
Adică probabilitatea
pentru rezultatul zero, reprezentată în albastru, este egală cu unu, iar probabilitatea pentru rezultatul unu, reprezentată în violet, este egală cu zero.
Aceasta este foarte simplu, dar putem de fapt să obținem
câteva informații suplimentare despre theta făcând asta.
De exemplu, dacă știm în avans că fie theta este egal cu zero fie theta este egal cu un sfert, atunci acest circuit ne va dezvălui
care dintre cele două posibilități este.
Pe de altă parte, nu mai putem distinge cazul că theta este egal cu zero de cazul că theta este egal cu o jumătate.
Deci această procedură nu este strict mai bună decât cea anterioară când
aveam un singur gate U controlat, dar rulând și acest circuit
putem câștiga informații suplimentare.
Nu este imediat clar
cum informațiile suplimentare pe care le putem obține iterând operația U controlată de mai multe ori
pot fi reconciliate cu
informațiile pe care le obținem efectuând-o o singură dată, și de fapt există mai multe
moduri în care am putea proceda.
De exemplu, există o tehnică numită estimarea de fază iterativă, care implică rularea circuitelor ca cele pe care le-am văzut,
împreună cu câteva variații minore ale acestora, pentru a obține o aproximare a lui theta.
Dar voi descrie
ceea ce s-ar putea numi o abordare mai tradițională, în care folosim un singur circuit cuantic care are mai mulți qubiți de control
care controlează diferite
numere de iterații ale operației unitare U.
Mai întâi voi descrie cum funcționează
asta pentru doi qubiți de control și apoi puțin mai târziu o vom generaliza la mai mult de doi qubiți de control.
Iată un circuit cuantic
care folosește doi qubiți de control.
Qubit-ul de control de sus
controlează o singură operație U, în timp ce qubit-ul al doilea de sus controlează două copii ale lui U.
Deci ceea ce facem este să combinăm cele două circuite pe care le-am văzut anterior, într-un mod care folosește singura copie
a vectorului propriu psi pe care o avem.
Vei observa totuși
că gate-urile Hadamard de după operațiile U controlate au fost eliminate și nu există încă măsurători.
Ceea ce vom face este să
vedem cum funcționează acest circuit și apoi ne vom da seama
ce ar trebui să facem cu primii doi qubiți
pentru a afla cât mai mult posibil despre valoarea theta pe care
încercăm să o aproximăm.
După efectuarea gate-urilor Hadamard, avem starea care
apare pe ecran.
WEBVTT
Și acesta va fi un mod convenabil de a scrie starea pentru
a vedea ce se întâmplă în continuare.
A zero și A unu sunt biți, iar dacă ne gândim la primii doi qubiți ca un registru de doi qubiți,
ne gândim la A zero, care corespunde qubit-ului de sus, ca bitul mai puțin semnificativ, iar A unu care corespunde
qubit-ului de control inferior
ca bitul mai semnificativ.
După efectuarea primei
operații U controlate, obținem această stare.
Starea clasică corespunzătoare qubit-ului de control de sus este A zero, deci rezultatul phase kickback
poate fi exprimat în acest mod. Apoi după a doua și
a treia operație U controlată
obținem această stare.
Ideea este aceeași ca pentru prima, cu excepția că de data aceasta aplicăm operația U controlată de două ori.
Deci înmulțim A unu cu doi în
exponent pentru a reflecta aceasta.
Și acum putem simplifica această expresie gândindu-ne la biții
A unu și A zero împreună ca un număr întreg între zero și
trei folosind notația binară.
Adică atunci când ne gândim
la șirul de doi biți, A unu A zero, ca
codificare binară a unui număr întreg,
ceea ce obținem este doi
ori A unu plus A zero.
Și înțelegerea este
că atunci când scriem Cat X, vorbim despre X scris ca șir binar de lungime
doi folosind notația binară.
Deci acum să ne concentrăm pe
acești doi qubiți de control pentru a afla ce putem
afla despre theta din ei în acest punct.
Cei N qubiți rămași sunt
în continuare în aceeași stare psi care ne-a fost dată inițial, ceea ce este cu adevărat un lucru minunat despre această abordare
deoarece cum am spus înainte, putem folosi acea stare din nou dacă vrem să câștigăm și mai multe
informații despre theta.
Dar pentru moment, să ne gândim la ce putem afla din
acești doi qubiți de control.
Pentru a ne ajuta să stabilim cum să procedăm, să ne imaginăm că ni se promite că theta este egal cu Y împărțit la patru
pentru un număr întreg y între zero și trei.
În general, theta poate să nu fie
una dintre aceste patru valori, dar acesta este un caz natural de luat în considerare.
Am văzut în versiunea originală cu un singur qubit de control a procedurii că dacă ni se promitea că theta este fie zero fie o jumătate
circuit-ul ar dezvălui care dintre ele era. Și am observat, de asemenea, că în versiunea în care aplicam operația U controlată de două ori,
puteam discrimina perfect cazul că theta este egal cu zero de cazul că theta
este egal cu un sfert.
Deci am putea spera că cu noul nostru circuit putem discrimina aceste patru cazuri.
În esență, ceea ce facem
este să folosim noțiunea de problemă cu promisiune
pentru a face problema mai ușoară, astfel încât să putem vedea cum să procedăm.
Și aceasta nu este o idee rea, în general. Dacă ai o problemă și nu
știi cum să o rezolvi, încearcă să o simplifici.
Dacă poți rezolva problema mai ușoară, perspectiva pe care o câștigi ar putea fi utilă în rezolvarea problemei mai generale.
Și dacă nu poți rezolva problema mai ușoară, probabil că nu ești pregătit
pentru problema mai generală.
Deci continuă să o simplifici
până când o poți rezolva.
Oricum, revenind la problema noastră, să definim o stare de doi qubiți pentru fiecare dintre valorile posibile ale lui Y.
Cu alte cuvinte, phi Y este egal cu starea
arătată în partea de sus a ecranului când theta este ales
specific ca Y împărțit la patru.
Și iată cele patru
stări scrise explicit.
Deci pentru a reitera, dacă
theta este egal cu Y împărțit la patru pentru Y fiind zero, unu, doi sau
trei și rulăm circuit-ul nostru,
vom rămâne cu
una dintre aceste patru stări, oricare corespunde
valorii corecte a lui Y.
Și vrem doar să aflăm
care este aceea.
Și întrebarea este, este aceasta posibil?
Iar răspunsul la acea întrebare este da, deoarece aceste patru stări sunt ortogonale.
Dacă calculezi produsul intern
între oricare pereche dintre ele, vei obține zero.
Și deoarece sunt ortogonale, ele pot fi discriminate perfect printr-o măsurătoare proiectivă.
Și în particular putem
exprima o astfel de măsurătoare definind o proiecție pentru fiecare vector cum avem aici.
Aceasta funcționează întotdeauna, oricând
avem o bază ortonormată, și poți verifica aceasta
față de definițiile pe care le-am văzut în lecția trei
pentru acest caz specific
dacă ești dispus. Deci concluzionăm că este
posibil să ne îndeplinim sarcina,
care este să aflăm valoarea lui Y din starea care apare
în partea de sus a ecranului.
Și dacă dorim să facem asta
cu un circuit cuantic, putem proceda cum voi explica acum.
Mai întâi putem defini o matrice unitară V ale cărei coloane sunt cei patru
vectori enumerați în ordine.
Acea matrice va avea acțiunea descrisă în partea de jos a ecranului,
pe stările bazei standard,
și putem scrie matricea
pentru a vedea cum arată.
Deoarece V mapează fiecare stare a bazei standard, kappa Y la vectorul phi Y, avem că aplicând V dagger,
sau cu alte cuvinte V invers la phi Y va transforma înapoi în celălalt sens la starea corespunzătoare a bazei standard.
WEBVTT
Deci ceea ce putem face este să aplicăm V dagger la orice stare am
obținut din circuit-ul nostru.
Și dacă efectuăm o
măsurătoare în baza standard, vom obține numărul Y
pe care îl căutăm, exprimat ca un șir
de lungime doi în binar.
Înainte de a merge mai departe, să vorbim puțin mai mult
despre matricea unitară V.
Aceasta este o matrice specială și
poate ai mai văzut-o.
Este matricea asociată
cu o operație liniară pe vectori de dimensiune patru, cunoscută ca transformata Fourier discretă.
Mai precis, transformata Fourier discretă poate fi definită pentru orice
dimensiune pozitivă întreagă, și o vom examina
în general în câteva momente.
Și acesta este cum arată
mai specific când dimensiunea este egală cu patru.
Putem gândi despre
transformata Fourier discretă în diferite moduri.
Putem gândi despre ea pur abstract ca o aplicare liniară pe vectori care poate fi reprezentată printr-o matrice.
Și putem gândi, de asemenea, despre
ea ca o problemă computațională în care ni se dă un vector și vrem să calculăm rezultatul
aplicării acestei aplicări liniare.
Aceasta se dovedește a fi o problemă computațională
incredibil de importantă, și există un algoritm extrem de eficient pentru efectuarea acelei computații
cunoscut ca transformata Fourier rapidă.
De fapt, aceasta este o problemă atât de importantă în procesarea semnalelor, de exemplu, că transformata Fourier
rapidă este considerată de mulți
a fi unul dintre cei mai importanți și mai influenți
algoritmi descoperiți vreodată.
Putem gândi, de asemenea, despre
transformata Fourier discretă ca o operație cuantică unitară care poate fi aplicată la
un vector de stare cuantică.
Și când gândim despre ea în acel mod, o numim transformata Fourier
cuantică, sau QFT pe scurt.
Din punct de vedere matematic, este practic același lucru ca transformata Fourier discretă, dar o numim transformata Fourier cuantică
doar pentru a clarifica că este o operație aplicată unui vector de stare cuantică.
Deci să schimbăm numele matricei noastre, din V în QFT patru pentru a reflecta faptul
că operația cu care am venit este de fapt transformata Fourier cuantică.
Iată deci circuit-ul complet pentru aflarea valorii lui Y când ni se promite că
theta este egal cu Y împărțit la patru
pentru Y fiind zero, unu, doi sau trei.
Și doar pentru a fi clar, aplicăm inversul
transformatei Fourier cuantice, sau cu alte cuvinte QFT patru dagger
pentru a mapa una dintre cele patru stări posibile înapoi la starea bazei standard, cat Y, astfel încât să putem recupera Y prin măsurare.
Deci acesta este circuit-ul pe care îl
obținem gândindu-ne la versiunea cu promisiune a
problemei estimării de fază, unde ni se promite că theta
este zero, un sfert, o
jumătate sau trei sferturi, dar nu există nimic care să ne împiedice
să rulăm acest circuit pentru
o valoare arbitrară a lui theta.
Și dacă facem asta, iată
probabilitățile pentru cele patru rezultate posibile
pe care le obținem.
Fiecare dintre cele patru valori posibile
pentru Y are propria culoare, iar graficul ne spune
care sunt probabilitățile pentru fiecare în funcție de theta.
Deci de exemplu, dacă theta
este egal cu trei sferturi, vom obține rezultatul
trei cu probabilitate unu,
în timp ce probabilitățile pentru celelalte trei rezultate sunt toate zero, cum știm deja gândindu-ne la versiunea cu promisiune a problemei.
Dacă theta este aproape de trei sferturi, dar nu exact trei sferturi, va exista o probabilitate nenulă asociată cu celelalte rezultate,
dar vom obține în continuare rezultatul
trei cu probabilitate mare.
Deci chiar dacă theta poate
să nu fie egal cu Y împărțit la patru, putem totuși gândi
despre rezultatul pe care îl obținem din măsurători împărțit la patru
ca o ghicire sau o
aproximare pentru theta.
Ghicirea poate fi greșită, dar totuși ne
oferă informații.
Și un lucru pe care îl
putem afla din grafic este că cele mai bune aproximări au întotdeauna cele mai mari
probabilități asociate lor.
Când spun cea mai bună aproximare, mă refer la orice valoare a lui Y împărțit la patru care este cel mai aproape de valoarea reală a lui theta,
în sensul modulo unu. Cel mai rău caz posibil este că theta este exact la jumătatea distanței între
două valori ale lui Y împărțit la patru.
De exemplu, dacă theta este egal
cu trei optimi sau 0.375, în acest caz vedem
că aproximările
un sfert și două sferturi
sau o jumătate sunt la fel de bune.
Deci în acest caz particular
există de fapt două cele mai bune aproximări în loc de una.
Și avem șanse egale să obținem rezultatul unu
și rezultatul doi.
Celelalte două rezultate zero și trei, care nu oferă aproximări foarte bune
la theta când împărțim la patru, apar de fapt cu o anumită probabilitate
care pare să fie chiar sub
10% în ambele cazuri.
Deci această procedură nu este perfectă, dar ne oferă informații.
Și este remarcabil că
indiferent de theta, suntem întotdeauna garantați să extragem fie cea mai bună aproximare
fie una dintre cele două cele mai bune aproximări când există egalitate, cu probabilitate
care pare să fie chiar peste 40%.
WEBVTT
Și cu cât theta este mai aproape de aproximare, cu atât mai mare este probabilitatea de a vedea valoarea corespunzătoare a lui Y.
Și acesta este un
îmbunătățire destul de semnificativă față de utilizarea unui singur qubit de control.
Aceasta este de fapt procedura de
estimare de fază când alegem să folosim doi qubiți de control.
Și ceea ce vom face în continuare este să generalizăm această
procedură într-un mod natural, în care nu ne oprim cu
doar doi qubiți de control
ci folosim oricâți
qubiți de control alegem.
Și vom vedea că prin
generalizarea procedurii, adăugând mai mulți qubiți de control, vom putea obține tot mai
aproximări mai precise ale lui theta. Și aceea va fi procedura generală
de estimare de fază.
Pentru a generaliza
procedura de estimare de fază de la doi qubiți de control
la oricâți alegem, va trebui să înțelegem
cum este definită transformata Fourier cuantică pentru alte dimensiuni.
Și va trebui, de asemenea, să discutăm cum poate fi implementată
cu un circuit cuantic.
Iată definiția
transformatei Fourier cuantice când dimensiunea este un
număr întreg pozitiv arbitrar N.
Aici gândim despre această operație ca o operație pe un sistem ale cărui stări clasice sunt
de la zero la N minus unu.
Și aici matricea care
descrie această operație a fost exprimată folosind
notația directă.
O putem descrie, de asemenea, în termeni de acțiunea sa
pe stările bazei standard, doar pentru a o conecta cu
ceea ce am văzut deja când N este egal cu patru.
Iată cum arată
când N este egal cu unu, care nu este un caz foarte interesant.
Iată pentru N egal cu doi, și vei observa că ceea ce obținem în acest caz este o operație Hadamard.
Iată transformata Fourier
cuantică pentru N egal cu trei.
Pentru N egal cu patru, pe care
deja am văzut-o.
Și pentru un ultim exemplu, iată când N este egal cu opt.
Exact cum am avut
pentru cazul N egal cu patru, acestea sunt matricele pe care le asociem cu transformata Fourier discretă
pentru fiecare dimensiune. Dar o numim
transformata Fourier cuantică când vrem să gândim despre
ea ca operație cuantică.
Uneori apropo, factorul de unu peste rădăcina pătrată din N nu este inclus când gândim despre transformata Fourier discretă ca matrice,
dar avem nevoie de acel factor aici pentru a ne asigura că obținem o matrice unitară.
Există uneori și un semn minus în fiecare exponent, dar nu întotdeauna.
Este practic doar o preferință personală care nu schimbă natura fundamentală
a transformatei.
Dar în orice caz, vom defini transformata Fourier cuantică cum este scrisă aici pe ecran.
Există o notație prescurtată foarte utilă
care este comună și o vom folosi
puțin mai târziu în lecție.
Și anume să definim un
număr complex omega N, cum avem aici.
Mai precis ca e la doi pi I împărțit la N, care poate fi scris, de asemenea,
folosind sinusuri și cosinusuri
cum avem chiar aici. Uneori numim
acest număr o rădăcină a unității de ordin N, deoarece când îl ridicăm
la puterea N, obținem unu.
Iată o figură care arată câteva exemple.
Omega unu este egal cu unu, omega doi este egal cu minus unu, iar omega patru este egal cu I.
În general, pentru a obține omega N, ne putem imagina că împărțim cercul unitar în N bucăți de dimensiuni egale ca o pizza împărțită de N persoane
și omega N este la
colțul primei bucăți, presupunând că celălalt colț
al acelei bucăți este la unu.
Deci în particular pe măsură ce N
devine tot mai mare, bucățile vor deveni tot mai mici, iar omega N va deveni
tot mai aproape de unu.
Și acum dacă folosim acea notație putem exprima
transformata Fourier cuantică într-un mod ușor mai clar.
Uneori această notație
ajută la simplificarea lucrurilor, cum vom vedea că se întâmplă
puțin mai târziu în lecție.
Există o implementare eficientă cu circuit cuantic a transformatei Fourier cuantice
când N este o putere a lui doi,
pe care o vom examina acum. Deși tindem să definim
transformata Fourier cuantică pentru orice dimensiune N,
o vom folosi numai
în cazul că N este o putere a lui doi, pentru a generaliza
procedura de estimare de fază.
Implementarea va face
uz de gate-uri de fază controlate, care sunt reprezentate cum
avem aici pe ecran.
Arată ca două
controale conectate împreună împreună cu un număr care
este alpha în acest caz.
Și acțiunea acestui gate este descrisă de matricea arătată aici.
Acestea sunt literalmente
gate-uri de fază controlate, adică avem un qubit de control care controlează un gate de fază.
Am văzut gate-urile de fază demult, în lecția unu.
Dar pentru gate-urile de fază în mod specific, de fapt nu contează
care qubit este controlul și care este ținta.
Și am văzut asta în lecția doi, pentru cazul specific al unui gate Z.
Și acum că avem acea noțiune, putem trece la modul în care
transformata Fourier cuantică poate fi implementată.
WEBVTT
Implementarea este recursivă în natură și poate cel mai simplu mod
de a o descrie în termeni simpli este să dăm un exemplu care
poate fi ușor generalizat.
Iată cum o putem face
când N este egal cu 32.
Deci există cinci qubiți.
Pentru a fi clar, asociem
stările bazei standard ale acestor cinci qubiți cu numerele întregi între zero și 31 folosind notația binară.
Primul lucru pe care îl facem este să efectuăm transformata Fourier
cuantică pentru N egal cu 16 la toți qubiții cu excepția
qubit-ului cel mai puțin semnificativ,
care este cel de sus. Și aceasta este
partea recursivă a construcției.
Deci pentru a implementa această operație, trebuie să urmăm același
model dar cu un qubit mai puțin.
Și în cazul de bază avem
un singur qubit pentru care transformata Fourier cuantică este doar un gate Hadamard.
Odată ce aplicăm QFT la toți qubiții cu excepția celui de sus, aplicăm o mulțime de gate-uri de fază controlate folosind fazele care sunt
indicate în diagramă.
Aplicăm apoi un gate Hadamard
la qubit-ul de sus, și rearanjăm qubiții puțin folosind câteva gate-uri swap.
Aceste gate-uri swap au efectul de a permuta ciclic qubiții, ceea ce este necesar pentru a face
construcția să funcționeze.
Putem urma exact același model pentru alte alegeri ale lui N
cu condiția că sunt puteri ale lui doi, unde începem întotdeauna gate-urile de fază controlate
cu alpha fiind pi împărțit la
doi pentru qubit-ul de jos și împărțind la doi de fiecare dată
deplasându-ne spre stânga în diagramă
pentru a obține fazele ulterioare. Acum nu este deloc evident
că această construcție funcționează.
Și nu voi explica
de ce funcționează în acest video.
Dacă ești interesat să vezi
detaliile despre de ce funcționează, le poți găsi în
materialul scris pentru lecție.
Voi spune totuși că
ceea ce este exploatat aici este structura de bază a
transformatelor Fourier discrete
și de fapt este exact
aceeași structură care permite transformatei
Fourier rapide să funcționeze.
Un alt mod de a spune asta este că dacă ne uităm la transformata Fourier rapidă, o putem gândi în
termeni de circuite cuantice.
Și acesta este circuit-ul pe care îl obținem.
Deci câte gate-uri avem nevoie în total pentru această implementare?
Pentru a afla asta, să lăsăm SM să fie numărul de gate-uri de care
avem nevoie când avem M qubiți.
Când M este egal cu unu, avem nevoie doar de un singur gate deoarece QFT este doar o operație Hadamard în acest caz.
Dacă M este cel puțin doi, atunci acestea sunt
gate-urile de care avem nevoie.
Mai întâi avem nevoie de SM minus unu gate-uri pentru transformata Fourier
cuantică pe M minus unu qubiți, oricare ar fi acel număr.
Avem nevoie, de asemenea, de M minus unu
gate-uri de fază controlate, M minus unu gate-uri swap,
și un gate Hadamard suplimentar.
Deci iată o expresie
a SM în ambele cazuri când M este egal cu unu și
când M este cel puțin doi.
Acesta este un exemplu a ceea ce se numește o relație de recurență și
apar foarte frecvent în analiza algoritmilor.
Aceasta în particular
se întâmplă să fie foarte simplă și are o expresie în formă
închisă, pe care o putem obține prin sumare.
Mai precis, valoarea lui SM este suma primelor M
numere întregi consecutive impare, care este egală cu M pătrat,
cum ai putea fi întâlnit înainte sau poate ai observat asta
la un moment dat în viata ta.
Și se dovedește a fi destul de ușor de demonstrat că această formulă este adevărată prin inducție pe M în
caz că ești interesat de o demonstrație formală.
Și gata. Putem implementa
transformata Fourier cuantică pe M qubiți folosind M pătrat gate-uri.
Doar câteva remarci suplimentare
foarte scurte.
În primul rând, de fapt nu
avem nevoie de toate gate-urile swap pe care le-am descris.
Este posibil să le
împingem efectiv toate la final, atât timp cât ajustăm pe care qubiți acționează gate-urile de fază controlate
în mod corespunzător.
Și dacă facem asta, vom avea nevoie numai
de M împărțit la doi gate-uri swap în total, rotunjind în jos.
Vom mai avea un cost pătratic, dar numărul de gate-uri poate fi redus în acest mod totuși.
Și o ultimă remarcă este că putem de fapt să facem costul și mai mic dacă suntem dispuși să acceptăm
o aproximare destul de bună.
De exemplu, când M devine mare, multe dintre gate-urile de fază controlate sunt destul de aproape de
operația identitate,
și eliminarea
celor care sunt foarte aproape ne poate economisi destul de mult pe gate-uri, oferindu-ne totuși o
aproximare destul de bună.
Este posibil, de asemenea, să aproximăm transformata Fourier cuantică
cu circuite foarte superficiale, adică cu adâncime mică, în caz că
dorim să facem asta.
Și acum că știm ce este
transformata Fourier cuantică pentru diferite dimensiuni, precum și cum poate fi implementată când dimensiunea este o putere a lui doi,
putem reveni la
procedura de estimare de fază și să vedem cum poate fi generalizată, în care folosim un număr arbitrar M de qubiți de control.
Iată cum arată procedura ca circuit cuantic pentru
o alegere arbitrară a lui M.
Avem M qubiți de control sus, pe care presupunem că sunt toți
inițializați la starea zero.
Aplicăm un gate Hadamard
la fiecare dintre ei și apoi fiecare este
folosit ca qubit de control pentru a aplica o putere a
operației unitare U,
WEBVTT
unde dublăm numărul
de ori în care U este aplicat pentru fiecare qubit de control.
Aici, în această diagramă, am indicat aceasta incluzând puterile
pe U înăuntrul casetelor, mai degrabă decât arătând gate-ul U controlat
aplicat de atâtea ori, ca modalitate de a face
diagrama mai clară și de a economisi spațiu astfel
încât să încapă pe ecran.
Acum primul lucru de care trebuie să ne dăm seama
despre această procedură este că ar putea deveni foarte costisitoare.
În particular, dublăm
numărul de ori în care fiecare operație U este aplicată
pentru fiecare qubit de control.
Și dacă modul în care facem asta este pur și simplu să iterăm un gate U controlat de câte ori avem nevoie,
vom obține un circuit imens. Va fi exponențial
de mare în numărul M.
Aceasta este o limitare majoră în general, și în particular limitează capacitatea noastră de a obține aproximări precise
ale valorilor proprii.
În cazul specific al factorizării totuși, la care vom ajunge în curând, se dovedește că suntem foarte norocoși și putem folosi un truc care ne permite
să evităm această explozie exponențială de cost.
Dar în general pentru operații
unitare U arbitrare, aceasta nu va fi posibil și
vom plăti un preț mare
pentru creșterea
numărului de qubiți de control.
Nu voi face
o analiză detaliată a circuit-ului în acest video și în schimb voi menționa doar că există o expresie destul de simplă pentru stare
chiar înainte de măsurători, care este arătată aici pe ecran.
Din acea stare putem obține o expresie pentru probabilitățile
diferitelor rezultate, și se dovedește că arată astfel.
Și odată ce avem această expresie,
putem raționa despre ea, și de fapt această expresie
este tot ce avem nevoie pentru a continua.
Cum am spus, nu voi intra în
detalii în acest video, dar le poți găsi în
materialul scris pentru lecție și se dovedește că de fapt nu este atât de complicat,
deci consultă-l dacă ești dispus. Dacă facem totuși analiza, ceea ce găsim este că situația
nu este atât de diferită
de cazul M egal cu doi, cu excepția că obținem mai multă precizie.
În particular, putem gândi
mai întâi la probabilitatea de a obține cea mai bună sau una dintre
cele două cele mai bune aproximări,
pe care o putem exprima cum avem aici.
Poți ignora acest indice de unu pe valoarea absolută dacă dorești.
Acesta este doar un simbol pe care îl
putem folosi pentru a ne reaminti că vorbim despre
aproximări pe cerc, unde gândim la theta egal zero
și theta egal unu ca fiind la fel. Ideea este că
gândim la orice alegere a lui Y care face Y împărțit la doi la puterea M
cât mai aproape posibil de theta.
Și încă o dată, exact cum am
avut pentru cazul M egal cu doi, suntem garantați să obținem acest rezultat Y cu probabilitate de cel puțin 40%.
De fapt, probabilitatea este
de cel puțin patru împărțit la pi pătrat, care este puțin mai mult de 40%.
Zece nu este o proastă
aproximare a lui pi pătrat când ești grăbit.
Și asta este cu adevărat remarcabil. Despre ce vorbim este să obținem cea mai bună
aproximare a lui theta ca fracție Y împărțit la doi la puterea M
unde Y este un număr întreg. Și obținem
cea mai bună aproximare cu probabilitate mai mare de 40%.
Putem gândi, de asemenea, la
aproximări care sunt mai proaste.
Mai precis, să ne imaginăm
că Y nu este tocmai atât de bun, și mai precis să presupunem
că există o aproximare mai bună
a lui theta de aceeași formă care se află între theta și Y împărțit la doi la M,
care poate fi exprimată cum
este scris pe ecran.
Într-un astfel de caz, probabilitatea
de a obține acest Y va fi relativ mică, cel mult 25%.
Va fi de fapt mai mică decât aceasta, dar 25% este ceea ce obținem dintr-o analiză destul de simplă, dar este suficient de bun.
Ca exemplu, iată graficul pe care îl obținem când folosim trei qubiți de control
în loc de doi.
De data aceasta reprezint
grafic numai probabilitățile pentru rezultatele trei, patru și cinci, deoarece nu vreau ca
figura să fie prea aglomerată.
Când theta este egal cu
o jumătate de exemplu, suntem garantați să obținem rezultatul patru.
Și deci luăm
aproximarea noastră ca patru optimi sau o jumătate, deoarece doi la
puterea trei este opt.
Și în acest caz avem exact dreptate. Și atât timp cât theta este mai aproape de o jumătate decât de, să zicem, trei
optimi de exemplu,
obținem rezultatul patru cu o probabilitate mai mare
decât rezultatul trei.
Și cu probabilitate,
din nou mai mare de 40%.
Iată graficul când M este egal cu patru. Și curbele arată de fapt
destul de identice, cu excepția că acum am
mărit cu un factor de doi.
Deci acum rezultatele reprezentate includ șapte, opt și nouă și luăm aproximarea ca unul dintre aceste numere
împărțit la 16 în loc de opt.
Și voi arăta încă un grafic în care creștem la M egal cu cinci.
Și din nou vom
mări cu un factor de doi.
Și iată. Odată din nou curbele arată
destul de identice, dar efectiv
ne dublăm precizia.
WEBVTT
Și cum am obținut înainte, cea mai bună aproximare la theta, cu probabilitate mai mare de 40%.
Asta este destul de uimitor. Dar dacă 40% nu este suficient
ca măsură a încrederii,
ceea ce putem face este să rulăm procedura de un număr mic de ori și
să luăm moda rezultatelor, adică cel care
apare cel mai frecvent.
Și dacă facem asta, este extrem de probabil să ajungem cu o aproximare foarte bună a lui theta.
Reamintim apropo că de fiecare dată când rulăm
procedura de estimare de fază avem că vectorul propriu
iese nemodificat.
Deci este disponibil pentru a rula procedura
de mai multe ori în acest mod.
Pe scurt, colectăm
statistici despre theta, iar ideea este că făcând aceasta putem obține o aproximare foarte precisă
a lui theta
cu mare încredere, și nu avem nevoie de atât de multe iterații ale procedurii pentru a face asta.
Și aceasta este modul în care
procedura de estimare de fază funcționează.
În ultima parte a lecției, vom aplica tehnica
estimării de fază la problema factorizării numerelor întregi.
Cum am menționat la începutul videoclipului, modul în care funcționează este că luăm în considerare o problemă intermediară cunoscută ca problema găsirii ordinului.
Vom vedea cum putem rezolva
problema găsirii ordinului folosind estimarea de fază, și apoi vom discuta pe scurt cum rezolvarea problemei găsirii ordinului
ne permite să factorizăm numere întregi eficient.
A doua parte este complet clasică și voi rezuma numai
ideea de bază în acest video.
Dar să începem cu
problema găsirii ordinului.
Mai întâi, să stabilim câteva
notații convenabile.
Pentru orice număr întreg pozitiv N, definim ZN ca numerele întregi
de la zero la N minus unu.
Deci, de exemplu, Z unu are un
singur element care este zero, Z doi are elementele zero și unu,
Z trei are elementele zero,
unu și doi, și tot așa.
Deci ZN este o mulțime.
Dar putem gândi despre
ea mai mult decât o mulțime. Putem gândi despre operații aritmetice cum ar fi adunarea și înmulțirea pe ZN
definind-le modulo N.
De exemplu, să presupunem
că N este egal cu șapte.
Avem că trei și cinci
sunt elemente ale lui Z șapte și dacă le înmulțim obținem 15
care lasă un rest de
unu după împărțirea la șapte.
Uneori exprimăm aceasta scriind că trei ori cinci este
congruent cu unu modulo șapte, cum este scris aici.
Dar putem, de asemenea, pur și simplu scrie că trei ori cinci este egal cu unu.
Desigur trei ori cinci
nu este în mod normal egal cu unu, este egal cu 15.
Dar când este clar că
lucrăm în Z șapte, adică că înmulțirea
este definită modulo șapte,
putem scrie pur și simplu că
trei ori cinci este egal cu unu.
Acum, printre elementele
lui ZN pentru orice N pozitiv, unele dintre ele vor avea
cel mai mare divizor comun egal cu unu cu N
iar altele nu. Iar elementele care au cel mai mare divizor comun egal cu unu cu N sunt speciale.
și scriem ZN stea pentru a ne referi la mulțimea doar a acestor elemente.
Deci, de exemplu, iată Z 21 stea.
Printre elementele lui Z 21, care sunt 21 la număr desigur, se dovedește că 12 dintre ele au cel mai mare divizor comun egal cu unu
cu 21, iar restul nu.
În particular, de fiecare dată că
avem un element al lui Z 21 care este divizibil fie prin
trei fie prin șapte, îl omitem.
Există diverse motive
pentru care această mulțime este specială, și unul dintre motive este că de fiecare dată când avem un element al lui ZN stea
și considerăm puterile pozitive
ale acelui număr, vom ajunge întotdeauna în cele din urmă
la numărul unu,
unde la fel ca înainte vorbim despre înmulțire modulo N.
cea mai mică putere pozitivă întreagă care ne dă unu se numește
ordinul acelui element.
De exemplu, gândite la elementul A egal cu patru în Z 21 stea.
Patru ori patru este 16, care nu este egal cu unu modulo 21, dar dacă înmulțim cu patru încă o dată,
obținem 64, iar 64 modulo
21 este egal cu unu.
Deci ordinul lui patru modulo 21 este trei.
Ajungerea la unu în acest mod se întâmplă întotdeauna pentru toate elementele lui ZN stea.
Și apropo, nu se
întâmplă niciodată pentru elementele lui ZN care nu sunt în ZN stea.
Deci a avea cel mai mare divizor comun egal cu
unu cu N în acest mod este atât necesar cât și
suficient pentru ca asta să se întâmple.
Și pentru a termina cu
exemplul N egal cu 21, iată cele mai mici
puteri pozitive întregi pentru care funcționează asta pentru
fiecare element al lui Z 21 stea,
și pot fi verificate una câte una.
Și acum putem formula
problema găsirii ordinului, care este pur și simplu să găsim ordinul pentru un element dat în ZN stea.
WEBVTT
Mai precis, intrarea este
doi numere întregi pozitive A și N pentru care cel mai mare divizor comun este egal cu unu,
iar ieșirea este cel mai mic
număr întreg pozitiv R astfel încât A la puterea R este
congruent cu unu modulo N,
sau echivalent cel mai mic
număr întreg pozitiv R pentru care A la R este egal cu unu.
Presupunând că facem aritmetică în ZN.
Se crede că aceasta este o
problemă computațional dificilă; nu se cunoaște niciun algoritm clasic eficient
pentru rezolvarea sa.
Și cum vom discuta, problema este cel puțin la fel de dificilă ca
factorizarea numerelor întregi, în sensul că dacă avem un algoritm pentru rezolvarea găsirii ordinului,
am putea folosi acel algoritm pentru a rezolva problema
factorizării numerelor întregi eficient.
De fapt, merge și în cealaltă direcție, adică dacă ai un algoritm pentru factorizare, îl poți folosi pentru a rezolva
problema găsirii ordinului.
Deci cele două probleme sunt
în anumite privințe echivalente în termeni de
dificultate computațională.
Acum vom vedea cum putem rezolva
problema găsirii ordinului pe un calculator cuantic
folosind estimarea de fază.
Pentru a face o legătură între probleme, să ne imaginăm că avem un sistem ale cărui stări clasice sunt AN.
Pentru orice alegere a unui element A în ZN stea, vom defini o operație
MA cum avem aici.
Cu cuvinte, ceea ce face MA este să înmulțească cu A, iar înmulțirea este modulo N.
Și pentru restul acestei lecții, ar trebui să te gândești întotdeauna la
expresiile din interiorul cat-urilor ca fiind calculate modulo N,
doar pentru a simplifica lucrurile și a nu fi nevoiți să scriem
mod N iar și iar.
Aceasta este o operație unitară, dar asta este adevărat numai
deoarece A este în ZN stea.
Dacă cel mai mare divizor comun al lui A și N nu este unu, această operație nu va fi unitară.
Iată un exemplu. Dacă N este egal cu 15 și A este egal cu doi, care este în Z 15 stea, atunci
aceasta este acțiunea lui M doi.
Și dacă examinezi
exemplul câteva momente, vei vedea că ceea ce se întâmplă este că elementele lui ZN sunt permutate de această acțiune.
Deci este atât deterministă cât și unitară, ceea ce înseamnă că, ca matrice, MA este o matrice de permutare.
Și iată ideea principală. Valorile proprii ale lui MA sunt
strâns legate
de ordinul lui A. Și folosind estimarea de fază pentru a aproxima aceste
valori proprii suficient de exact
putem determina ordinul lui A. Deci care sunt exact vectorii proprii și valorile proprii ale lui MA?
Ei bine, nu vom avea nevoie de toți, avem nevoie numai de unii dintre ei.
Să începem cu un exemplu ușor.
Iată un vector propriu al lui MA, l-am numit psi zero, și este dat de
suma cat unu, cat a,
cat A pătrat, și tot așa până la cat A la puterea R minus unu, totul împărțit la rădăcina pătrată din R
pentru a-l face un vector unitar. Aici R este ordinul lui A.
Și voi rezerva
litera R pentru ordinul lui A pentru restul lecției.
Deci ori de câte ori vezi R, acesta este ordinul lui A pentru
oricare A despre care vorbim.
Valoarea proprie asociată
cu acest vector propriu este unu.
Și putem verifica asta prin
aplicarea lui MA la acest vector pentru a vedea ce obținem.
MA înmulțește cu A, deci
avem nevoie doar să creștem fiecare exponent cu
unu și asta este ceea ce obținem.
Dar ordinul lui A este R, deci A la puterea R este egal cu unu.
Și putem face acea substituție.
Dar acesta este același vector
cu care am pornit. Tot ce am făcut este să
rearanjăm cat-urile, dar luăm suma deci
asta nu schimbă nimic.
Deci MA ori psi zero este egal cu psi zero.
Deci este un vector propriu al lui
MA cu valoarea proprie unu.
Acesta este un exemplu foarte simplu
de vector propriu, și pentru a identifica mai mulți dintre ei, să reapelăm aceeași notație pe care am avut-o mai devreme în lecție.
Omega R este numărul complex
de pe cercul unitar pe care îl obținem luând E la
puterea doi ori pi ori I
împărțit la R. Ultima dată aveam un N în loc de R, dar funcționează la fel
pentru R în locul lui N.
Avem nevoie de acest număr deoarece
va apărea în ceilalți vectori proprii
ai lui MA pe care îi vom identifica.
Și acum că am reapelat acea notație, putem observa că acest
vector numit psi unu este de asemenea un vector propriu al lui MA.
Este similar cu psi zero, avem exact aceleași cat-uri și le sumăm și
împărțim la rădăcina din R.
Dar de data aceasta avem diverse faze înmulțind fiecare dintre cat-uri.
Omega R la minus unu pentru A, omega R la minus doi pentru A pătrat, și tot așa până la omega R la
puterea minus R minus unu
pentru A la puterea R minus unu. Deci puterea lui omega R
este întotdeauna minus unu ori orice putere a lui A
apare înăuntrul cat-ului.
Nu voi parcurge asta în detaliu, dar este arătat pe ecran în caz că dorești să revezi videoclipul și să faci pauză dacă e necesar.
Dar dacă facem înmulțirea și simplificăm din nou folosind faptul că A la puterea R este egal cu unu
precum și faptul foarte important că omega la puterea R este egal cu unu, ceea ce vom găsi este că avem
din nou un vector propriu al lui MA.
WEBVTT
De data aceasta în timp ce facem simplificarea, va trebui să scoatem un factor de omega R pentru a vedea că avem într-adevăr un vector propriu
și că acel vector omega R reprezintă valoarea proprie asociată cu acest vector propriu.
Deci acesta este al doilea vector propriu-
valoare proprie pereche al lui NA.
Putem identifica vectori proprii suplimentari folosind exact același raționament, și de fapt, dacă înlocuim pur și simplu omega R
cu omega R la puterea J pentru fiecare J între zero și R minus unu, vom obține întotdeauna un vector propriu,
iar valoarea proprie asociată va fi omega R la puterea J.
Deci aceasta include de fapt
psi zero și psi unu, pe care le-am văzut deja,
precum și R minus doi alte perechi vector propriu-valoare proprie.
Toate funcționează practic la fel, și pentru a le verifica avem nevoie doar să știm că A la puterea R este egal cu unu
precum și că omega R la
puterea R este egal cu unu.
Există alți vectori proprii ai lui MA cum ar fi cat zero de exemplu, dar aceștia nu ne vor fi utili și nu trebuie să ne facem griji despre ei.
Trebuie să ne facem griji numai despre psi zero până la psi R minus unu.
Să ne concentrăm pe psi unu pentru un moment, doar pentru a înțelege de ce contează acești vectori proprii
și ce ne pot spune
despre ordinul R, care este ceea ce încercăm să găsim.
Presupunând că ni se dă
vectorul propriu psi unu, putem încerca să aflăm
R în felul următor.
Mai întâi, efectuăm estimarea de fază
pe acest vector propriu folosind un circuit cuantic care
implementează operația MA.
Ceea ce obținem este o aproximare la theta, care este unu împărțit la R în acest caz.
Și în al doilea rând, deoarece căutăm R și avem o
aproximare la unu împărțit la R, lucrul natural de făcut este
să calculăm reciproca
și să rotunjim la
cel mai apropiat număr întreg. Trebuie să rotunjim astfel
deoarece R trebuie să fie un număr întreg.
Dar nu avem unu din R exact, avem doar o aproximare la el.
Dar dacă aproximarea este suficient de bună, vom obține R când rotunjim,
ceea ce este ceea ce căutăm.
Și acum întrebarea este cât de multă precizie avem nevoie pentru a determina corect R calculând reciproca și rotunjind?
Sau cu alte cuvinte, cât de exactă trebuie să fie aproximarea noastră pentru a face totul să funcționeze?
Ei bine, se dovedește că avem nevoie de o aproximare destul de exactă.
De exemplu, nu ne putem permite
să confundăm unu împărțit la R cu unu împărțit la R plus unu, sau unu împărțit la R minus unu de exemplu.
Acele două fracții, unu împărțit la R plus unu și
unu împărțit la R minus unu sunt destul de aproape de unu
împărțit la R când R este mare.
Dar deși avem nevoie de o
aproximare destul de exactă, nu avem nevoie de o aproximare ridicol de
exactă, și se poate arăta că dacă aproximarea noastră
satisface inegalitatea pe care
o avem aici pe ecran, atunci rotunjind vom
obține răspunsul corect.
Nu voi încerca să argumentez asta în acest video, dar este arătat în materialul
scris pentru lecție în caz că ești interesat de detalii.
Și dacă aceea este precizia
pe care o urmărim, atunci este suficient să folosim un
număr de qubiți de control în procedura de estimare de fază
egal cu de două ori
lungimea lui N plus unu.
Unde cum am avut în lecțiile anterioare, lungimea lui N este numărul de biți de care avem nevoie pentru a exprima N în binar.
Apropo, dacă ne mulțumim
să obținem cea mai bună aproximare cu probabilitate de cel puțin 40% și nu încercăm să
creștem încrederea noastră
cum am descris mai devreme, atunci de fapt nu avem nevoie de plus unu.
Dar în orice caz, avem că numărul
de qubiți de control de care avem nevoie este liniar în lungimea lui N
scris ca șir binar.
Am văzut că dacă avem
vectorul propriu psi unu, putem folosi estimarea de fază pentru a găsi R, cu condiția să folosim suficientă precizie.
Din nefericire nu este atât de ușor să punem mâna pe acest vector propriu.
Deci să punem o întrebare diferită.
Să presupunem că nu avem psi unu, ci avem psi
pentru o alegere aleatoare a lui J.
Putem totuși să aflăm ce este R? Sau cel puțin putem
afla ceva despre R?
Și răspunsul este da, putem afla ceva
despre R, cel puțin în medie.
Ceea ce putem face este să încercăm
să aflăm J împărțit la R folosind o metodă foarte similară
cu cea pe care tocmai am văzut-o,
dar cu o diferență cheie.
Mai întâi, vom face exact
același lucru pe care l-am făcut înainte, care este să rulăm procedura de
estimare de fază pe vectorul propriu psi J.
Și ceea ce vom obține este o
aproximare la J împărțit la R, spre deosebire de unu împărțit la R,
ceea ce aveam înainte.
Dar acum avem o mică problemă, deoarece calcularea
reciprocei nu ne va da R, ne va da R împărțit la J.
Și apropo, nu
presupunem că știm ce este J, ni se dă pur și simplu psi J pentru un J aleator,
și nu ni se spune ce este J. Deci ce putem face?
Ei bine, se dovedește că există un
algoritm clasic binecunoscut care ne poate ajuta, numit
algoritmul fracțiilor continue.
Și ceea ce poate face acest algoritm este să ia aproximarea noastră
Y împărțit la doi la M și să ne spună care fracție U împărțit la V,
scrisă în termeni reduși, și unde U și V sunt ambele
numere întregi mai mici decât N, este cea mai apropiată de aproximarea noastră.
WEBVTT
Este un algoritm cu adevărat fascinant, și dacă ești interesat de el, ar trebui să îl consulți cu siguranță.
Este strâns legat de algoritmul lui Euclid pentru
calcularea celui mai mare divizor comun de fapt.
Dar nu voi spune nimic
mai mult despre el în acest video.
Ideea este că dacă avem o bună
aproximare la o fracție pentru care numărătorul și
numitorul nu sunt prea mari,
algoritmul poate recupera fracția, și asta facem noi aici.
Și acum am rămas cu exact
aceeași întrebare ca înainte, care este cât de multă precizie avem nevoie?
Și se dovedește că
exact aceeași limită pe care o aveam înainte funcționează în acest caz.
Și deci alegerea lui M în exact
același mod ca înainte funcționează și aici.
Acum aceasta nu este neapărat
să ne spună R.
Ceea ce vom afla dacă folosim
suficientă precizie, este J împărțit la R, dar aceea va fi o
fracție în termeni reduși.
Deci am putea fi ghinionist în sensul că această alegere aleatoare a lui J ar putea avea factori comuni cu R,
și vor fi ascunși de noi. În cel mai rău caz, de exemplu, am putea obține J egal cu zero și nu vom afla absolut nimic.
Dar acela este literalmente singurul
caz în care nu aflăm nimic.
În general, vom obține cel puțin
un factor netrivial al lui R, și dacă reușim să extragem eșantioane aleatorii
și să obținem psi J pentru alegeri diferite ale lui J, putem de fapt să recuperăm
R cu probabilitate mare calculând cel mai mic multiplu comun
al tuturor numitorilor
pe care le observăm. Și asta de fapt nu
necesită foarte multe eșantioane.
Concluzia este că unele alegeri ale lui J vor ascunde factori ai lui R, dar alegerile aleatorii ale lui J
nu vor reuși să ascundă
factorii lui R mult timp.
Deci aceea este ideea. Rămâne să luăm în considerare implementarea și în particular să aflăm
cât costă.
Esența ideii, pentru a calcula ordinul unui
element A dat în ZN stea, este să aplicăm procedura de estimare de fază
la operația MA.
Să aflăm care
este costul de a face asta în funcție de lungimea lui N, pe care o voi nota cu n mic.
Iată un circuit pentru estimarea de fază. Vom avea nevoie de n mic qubiți în partea de jos a circuit-ului
pentru a codifica elementele lui ZN în binar. Deci avem N qubiți de control sus și n mic qubiți jos,
ceea ce este convenabil deoarece se potrivește cu numele pe care le
am folosit mai devreme în lecție.
Pentru a număra
numărul de gate-uri de care avem nevoie pentru întregul circuit, să ne concentrăm mai întâi pe costul operațiilor unitare controlate.
Dacă folosim tehnicile
din lecția anterioară, lecția șase, putem implementa MA folosind big O din n mic pătrat gate-uri
folosind algoritmi clasici eficienți pentru aritmetică modulo N.
Voi sări detaliile în acest video, dar ca mai multe alte
lucruri despre care am vorbit, poți citi mai mult despre asta în materialul scris pentru lecție.
Nu este suficient totuși
să implementăm numai MA.
Avem nevoie, de asemenea, să implementăm MA pătrat, MA la puterea a patra, la
puterea a opta, și tot așa
până la MA la o putere care este exponențială în M.
Și știm că va trebui să luăm M liniar în n mic
pentru a obține suficientă precizie.
Aceasta este o preocupare majoră,
și am ridicat-o mai devreme.
Dacă am implementa puterile
lui MA pur și simplu iterând MA, am fi în dificultate deoarece toate aceste iterații ale lui MA
ar implica cost exponențial.
Din fericire, putem folosi un truc pentru a evita această explozie de cost.
Ceea ce putem face este după cum urmează, pentru fiecare putere K de care avem nevoie.
Mai întâi, calculăm A la
puterea K, modulo N.
Aceasta este problema exponențierii modulare pe care am menționat-o în lecția șase.
Și poate fi rezolvată eficient. Și aceasta este ceva ce putem face cu un calculator clasic.
Această computație nu
trebuie să fie efectuată de un circuit cuantic.
Deci să lăsăm B să fie rezultatul.
Deci B este un element al lui ZN stea.
Și în al doilea rând, în locul lui MA la puterea K, folosim pur și simplu un circuit pentru MB.
Și asta e tot. B este doar un element al lui ZN stea, deci costul de a implementa MB
este big O din n mic pătrat.
Pe scurt, ceea ce facem este să exponentăm în ZN în loc să exponentăm
un circuit cuantic.
Dar operația reală pe care
o obținem este aceeași în ambele feluri. Este pur și simplu înmulțirea cu A, de K ori.
Acesta este cumva un miracol de fapt. Și nu am putea
rezolva problema găsirii ordinului sau factoriza numere întregi eficient
cu un calculator cuantic
dacă nu ar fi pentru aceasta.
Și acum că știm că fiecare dintre operațiile unitare controlate, inclusiv puterile, poate fi implementată
la cost big O din n pătrat, putem număra numărul total
de gate-uri de care avem nevoie.
Avem N gate-uri Hadamard, și deoarece M este egal
cu big O din n mic, costul este big O din n mic.
WEBVTT
Avem M operații unitare controlate care au fiecare un cost big O din N pătrat.
Deci costul total aici
este big O din N cub.
Și în fine, transformata Fourier cuantică are cost big O din n pătrat.
Deci costul total este big O din N cub.
În particular, vedem că chiar și cu trucul nostru al exponențierii modulare, costul operațiilor unitare controlate domină.
Dar cu toate acestea, costul
este polinomial în n mic.
Există, de asemenea, câteva computații clasice necesare, cum ar fi calcularea exponențierilor modulare și rularea algoritmului fracțiilor continue,
dar acele computații
au, de asemenea, cost polinomial. Și de fapt, pot fi efectuate în big O din N cub operații de asemenea.
Mai rămâne o singură problemă, și anume că trebuie să punem mâna pe unul dintre acești vectori proprii.
Cum putem face asta?
Soluția este de fapt foarte simplă. Nu rulăm circuit-ul
pe un vector propriu.
Pur și simplu îl rulăm pe starea unu, adică codificarea binară
a numărului unu, pe care o gândim
ca element al lui ZN.
Deci să facem
acea înlocuire în diagramă.
Motivul pentru care funcționează este această ecuație de aici.
Starea cat unu este de fapt
o superpozitie uniformă a celor R vectori proprii despre care
am vorbit.
Și asta nu este imediat evident, dar dacă calculezi
suma, ar trebui să obții cat unu.
Și dacă rulăm circuit-ul pe această stare, ieșirea pe care o vom obține
va fi exact aceeași ca și cum am fi ales aleator J
și am fi rulat procedura pe
vectorul propriu psi J.
Din nou, asta nu este evident, dar o analiză arată că este adevărat.
Și în fine, asta e tot. Avem un algoritm cuantic eficient pentru găsirea ordinului.
Mai rămâne o parte
foarte scurtă a lecției și privește relația dintre factorizarea numerelor întregi
și găsirea ordinului.
Am menționat că dacă putem rezolva problema găsirii ordinului eficient, atunci putem, de asemenea, factoriza
numere întregi eficient.
Și vreau să vă dau pe scurt ideea principală despre cum funcționează asta.
Este complet clasică. Această parte de fapt nu are
nimic de-a face cu calculul cuantic.
Iată o metodă pentru găsirea
unui factor netrivial al unui număr întreg pozitiv dat N.
Și apropo, această metodă funcționează numai când N este un număr impar, și nu este un număr prim
ridicat la o putere.
Acele două cazuri când N
este par sau o putere de număr prim pot fi gestionate separat.
Există metode clasice eficiente atât pentru detectarea cât și pentru
gestionarea acestor două cazuri.
Această metodă este probabilistică. S-ar putea să eșueze, dar probabilitatea
de eșec va fi de cel mult o jumătate,
și putem pur și simplu să o rulăm
de mai multe ori independent pentru a reduce probabilitatea
de eroare exponențial de rapid.
Mai întâi, alegem A între
doi și N minus unu la întâmplare, uniform.
Apoi calculăm cel mai mare divizor comun al lui A și N.
Și dacă cel mai mare divizor comun se dovedește
a fi mai mare decât unu, atunci tocmai am fost incredibil de norocoși.
Cel mai mare divizor comun va fi un factor al lui N și îl putem pur și simplu returna și opri.
Altfel, algoritmul continuă și știm acum că A este în ZN stea.
Și acum calculăm ordinul lui A, ceea ce este locul unde avem nevoie de un calculator cuantic.
Sau poate avem o altă
modalitate de a calcula ordinul. Algoritmul nu prea
contează de unde vine, dar singura modalitate pe care o știm
cum să facem asta eficient
este cu un calculator cuantic.
Dacă ordinul lui R este par, atunci calculăm cel mai mare divizor comun al lui
A la puterea R împărțit la doi minus unu cu N.
Și dacă acel cel mai mare divizor comun este mai mare decât unu, atunci din nou avem un factor al lui N, deci îl returnăm și ne oprim.
Altfel algoritmul a eșuat. Și în acel caz, putem
reveni la început și alege un alt A
și sperăm la un
rezultat mai bun data viitoare.
Și asta e tot. Și apropo, odată ce
am găsit un factor al lui N, putem recurge pe acel factor
și împărțim la el până când avem o factorizare primă a lui N.
Deci de ce ar trebui să funcționeze asta?
Ei bine, există două puncte principale. Primul este că deoarece A la puterea R este congruent cu unu modulo N,
avem că N divide A
la puterea R minus unu.
Cele două afirmații
sunt de fapt echivalente. Aceasta este definiția lui mod N pe care o vei găsi în cărțile de teoria numerelor.
În al doilea rând, dacă R este par, atunci această ecuație pe care
o avem aici este adevărată.
Aceasta este formula bine-cunoscută
pentru o diferență de pătrate.
De fapt, ecuația este adevărată pentru toate R, dar avem nevoie ca R împărțit la doi să fie
un număr întreg în pasul patru.
WEBVTT
Și deci dacă punem cele două fapte împreună, vedem că fiecare factor prim al lui N trebuie să dividă una dintre cele două
expresii din paranteze,
deoarece acesta este singurul mod
în care N poate divide produsul.
Acum, s-ar putea ca fiecare
singur factor prim al lui N să dividă prima
expresie din paranteze și nu cea de-a doua, dar pentru A-ul nostru aleator,
asta nu este foarte probabil. Și deci când calculăm
cel mai mare divizor comun în pasul patru, este probabil să obținem produsul
unor factori primi ai lui N, dar nu ai tuturor.
A analiza asta cu atenție
necesită câteva noțiuni de teoria numerelor, dar este teoria numerelor destul de elementară.
Deci dacă găsești teoria
numerelor interesantă și ai vrea să înveți mai mult despre ea, încearcă să parcurgi această analiză.
A parcurge lucruri de genul acesta este o modalitate excelentă de a învaț mai mult, dar te las pe tine să faci asta.
Și aceasta este sfârșitul lecției. În această lecție, am acoperit
problema estimării de fază, cum o putem rezolva eficient
pe un calculator cuantic,
și cum putem aplica soluția pentru a obține un algoritm cuantic de cost polinomial pentru factorizarea numerelor întregi.
Sper că te vei alătura mie pentru lecția următoare, care este despre
algoritmul de căutare cuantică al lui Grover.
La revedere până atunci.